delegates from myanmar's government have
visited rohingya refugee camps in
Bangladesh as part of a repatriation
scheme it's the second such visits in
the past three months well both
countries want to send more than one
thousand rohingya to Myanmar some
refugees say they've been pressured into
signing repatriation documents about a
million fled Myanmar in 2017 after a
military Crackdown
tambia Chowdhury spoke to rohingya
refugees in Cox's Bazaar where few trust
the repatriation plan
nearly 1.2 million rohingya refugees now
living in the world's largest refugee
camp cramped into barely 17 square
kilometer area their main hope is to
return to Myanmar there's a glimmer of
hope now there's an effort by the
Bangladesh government China and Myanmar
to repatriate as a pilot project more
than 1 000 refugees back to Myanmar very
shortly now A Team also visited Myanmar
to find out how the situation is there
most of doing as we spoke to who visited
this place as well as some of the
rohingyas who are in the shortlist said
they do want to return some even
volunteered to redone others said the
situation is not conducive they'll be
kept in a camp and like many of their
hangers are already there in Myanmar who
are kept in intern chem they said that's
not conducive we want to be recognized
as rohingya as an ethnic group we want
to have citizenship not just a
verification card which says Bengali
Muslim no other identity the most
importantly they want to go back to to
their ancestral villagers be at their
original home not stuck in the interim
Camp that's and they also want a third
party to be security guarantor so this
is a sticking point they said they're
skeptical because they think it's for
Optics and the Myanmar is trying this
they're not serious on another hand
there is a Russian cut in the community
because the wfp said that to cut Russian
in March from 12 to 10 and on June one
they're gonna cut it to eight dollar
that'll come to U.S nine cents per
person per meal every day that's grossly
inadequate already 45 percent of the men
my refugees rohingya refugees in other
words who are facing inadequate Foods as
part of the Russian and the world food
program said they need at least 56
million US Dollars this year in order to
keep the status quo as it was before so
there's a major crisis unless the
internet National Community step up with
the donation
the food crisis could increase here and
becoming a major and could become a
major issue in this refugee camp
well let's talk to nice and Lewin a
Burmese human rights activist and
co-founder of the free rohingya
Coalition thank you very much for being
on this NewsHour now as we heard from
tamvir uh just before he spoke to many
refugees there who don't trust this plan
do you trust it
well the same military committed the
Grievous International crime of genocide
against the rohingya people now this
military is offering the reputation of
this rohingya Survivor of Neymar
genocide so basically this uh the
military has been committing the
international crime against the other
Myanmar populations for the past two
years so in the country every day
killing is ongoing burning the houses so
this military is keep committing that
all the crime against entire population
in the country while doing so they are
offering the repetition which is not
trustable at all and also they have
bailed their concentration camp with the
barbed wire and the godpose of where you
know the the returning will not be
allowed to live from the discount so
this is like this repetition is like
moving from Bangladeshi a refugee camp
to the concentration camp in Myanmar so
my fellow rohingya Refugee in Bangladesh
came they don't trust at all I myself
also I don't trust this military at all
so how's it got to the stage then where
there's a plan in place
ah
well you know there is only one solution
that countries under military
detectorship
again so what we all need to try is to
take down that this military uh region
uh uh from the uh the country capital
nepilo uh bring back the uh bring the
this civilian uh government in the
country then we can start process about
this rohingya reputation under that this
military leadership it will not be
possible but as of now there are a lot
of you know pressure mounting on the
rohingya
refugee to take this so-called pilot
repetition uh in Boston especially
yesterday the The Authority make the
announcement that you know whoever
willing to take the take part in this
repetition they will be offer
a US dollar two thousand Pub family as
in incentive so there are a lot of
people today morning they are at the you
know at the authority office that they
are giving their name so this should not
be happened this is like you know
they're giving them incentive and you
know letting them go to their killing
field
okay when could we see a possible
repatriation date
he uh possibly tomorrow first job uh
because just a few days ago uh some of
the senior military officials came down
to the Border uh with you know they uh
they brought the same chef and you know
also the food uh find the refugee
arrived they can coop and sub you know
they get them in the camp so that they
were planning everything so there are
some refugees at the transit center in
Costa's Bazaar or you know at the border
area so uh I think about the 20 or 25
refugees there so I think they will be
refrigerated as a fast badge okay thank
you so much for your time that is nice
and Lewin a human rights activist and
co-founder of the free rohingya
Coalition thank you